here are some live pictures from a
polling station in beirut our
correspondent zaina hodder spoke to
voters in the lebanese capital about the
issues that matter most to them
lebanon has had a turbulent history to
say the least but decades of corruption
and unsustainable spending by successive
governments has led to its financial
collapse
parliamentary elections are scheduled
for sunday it should be a chance for
political change but the sectarian
leaders and parties that have governed
this country for decades are seeking to
return to power
they will win because they are the
authority they are ruling the country
they are organizing the elections they
benefit from the laws and they have arms
public sentiment may have turned against
them but these leaders still command
loyalty for ideological and sectarian
reasons despite the inability of the
state to provide services
uh
we have trust in them and that is why we
will vote for them like we did in the
past we don't trust the others
lebanese society is divided along
religious lines and has a power sharing
system leaders have become stronger than
the state by controlling its resources
and institutions
the established traditional parties
still have a captive constituency they
still offer a series of clientelistic
services and patronage and money
lebanese sectarianism allows them to
remain in office they keep presenting
themselves as victims they keep
portraying their opponents as going
after their communities rights
repeated attempts by protesters to bring
change were met by violence in some
regions intimidation and pressure are
expected to affect voting
[Music]
for the past 30 years a halo of fear
for the
in the south and people cannot say that
they are
tired that enough is enough
confronting the status quo won't be easy
there is a crisis of confidence between
the ruling class and the people but the
alternative is divided and weak and the
current system a state which is now all
but absent means a struggling population
becomes more dependent on their leaders
sunday's election is supposed to be a
turning point to set lebanon on the path
of recovery but many fear nothing will
change in the way politicians run this
country
senator al jazeera beirut